[Musik]
klirrende Kälte Schnee und Eis der
Winter wird zur Waffe im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine und darüber wollen wir heute
sprechen mit Deutschlands einzigen
Professor für Militärgeschichte so ein
kneipsel herzlich willkommen hallo
wir laufen ja nun auf Weihnachten zu am
24.12 wird es genau 10 Monate her sein
das Putin die Ukraine angegriffen hat
geben Sie das vielleicht eine kurze
Zwischenbilanz zunächst wie steht es
dort na also zunächst gibt es die
Ukraine noch das ist erstmal die gute
Nachricht als der Krieg los ging am 24
Februar haben wir glaube ich alle
gedacht ähm oder viele gedacht das ist
nur eine Sache von Tagen und und wird
die Ukraine in diesem Angriff
standhalten ja sie kann standhalten sie
konnte standhalten es gibt die Ukraine
noch es gibt die Regierung noch es gibt
silence noch und es gibt auch die
ukrainische Armee als eine funktionale
Institution noch aber jetzt kommen wir
in den ersten Kriegswinter und im Winter
sind die Kampfbedingungen natürlich
immer schwieriger für die Soldaten denn
dieser Kampf findet ja sagen auf dem
freien Feld zum großen Teil statt und
das kann jeder im Selbstversuch
nachempfinden bei dieser Witterung
draußen zu übernachten in schlammigen
Gräben
das ist eine große Herausforderung für
Mensch und Material und dem sitze ich
jetzt die ukrainische Seite gegenüber
übrigens auch die russische Seite nicht
beide kämpfen ja unter denselben
Bedingungen nun bombardieren ja die
Russen offenbar seit Wochen gezielt die
Energieversorgung der Ukraine das heißt
da kommt dann noch mal was drauf im
Unterschied zu russischen Bevölkerung
die Sie gerade erwähnt haben was macht
das mit den Menschen es gibt immer
wieder Blackouts der Strom muss
abgestellt werden es werden überall
Wärmestuben gegründet niemand der noch
da geblieben ist kann sich darauf
verlassen dass er in seinem Haus bleiben
kann
das sind ja vermutlich auf
psychologische Mittel der Kriegsführung
wieder eingesetzt hat was macht das mit
den Menschen was wissen sie darüber
ja also die Bedingungen sind natürlich
katastrophal also wir haben Menschen die
in Kiew in Ihrem Wohnzimmer Zelten und
eben nur vier Stunden Strom haben und es
ist kalt es ist zwar jetzt nicht so kalt
wie seit 41 42 oder bei Napoleon mit -40
Grad aber es ist unter dem Gefrierpunkt
und das sind Lebensbedingungen im die
natürlich völlig andere sind als die in
denen wir leben die große Frage ist
welchen Einfluss hat das eigentlich auf
den Krieg und wenn wir Reportagen sehen
es ist eine enorme Herausforderung wie
ich sagte für die für die Menschen dort
in den Städten aber die Frage
bricht damit die ukrainische Moral das
ist sicherlich das was Putin und seine
generelle wollen dass Sie Druck auf die
Zwiebel Bevölkerung ausüben also im
Sinne von Flüchtlinge oder wenn sie denn
da sind da bleiben Druck auf selenski
aber ich kann nur als Historiker sagen
ich sage mal jetzt hart formuliert
Terror hat eigentlich noch nie einen
Krieg entschieden und wir können das
Vergleichen so ein bisschen mit dem
Luftkrieg im strategischen Luftkrieg im
Zweiten Weltkrieg das sind
Jahrhunderttausende gestorben Städte
wurden zerstört und die Hoffnung war
immer von den Krieg führenden dann wird
es irgendwie eine Revolution geben oder
so und das hat eigentlich nie dazu
geführt sondern die Bevölkerung wurde
fatalistisch aber sie hat sich nicht
aufgelehnt und deswegen glaube ich auch
so schlimm das ist in Kiew und in Levi
und den anderen Orten ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das den Krieg
entscheidet das ist ein weiterer Puzzle
Stein es macht es für die Ukraine
schwerer auch die Truppen zu versorgen
wenn der Strom unterbrochen ist mit der
Eisenbahn zu fahren und so aber ich
glaube dass die Kriegsentscheidung auf
anderen Fällen getroffen wird und nicht
darüber die Fragen gerade eben selber
schon von der Moral in der Bevölkerung
die sehr hoch gehalten ist die wird ja
nun vor allen Dingen auch seit Monaten
sehr hoch gehalten von Präsident
selenski der ist ja immer wieder an sein
Volk wendet und ermöglicht ist immer
wieder ermutigt und natürlich auch
international überall Auftritt die
zweite wirklich sehr prominente Figur in
dem Spiel kann man nicht sagen in diesem
Konflikt ist Vitali Klitschko der
Bürgermeister von Kiew die beiden sind
bislang wahrnehmbar immer sehr
solidarisch aufgetreten inzwischen
erreichen uns Meldungen dass es da
anfängt ein bisschen zu kriseln selensky
hat gesagt wir müssen landesweit
Wärmestuben schaffen und hat Klitschko
dafür kritisiert dass er da nicht genug
tun würde für die 3 Millionen Einwohner
von Kiews wie wichtig ist Einigkeit in
so einer Führung oder was bedeutet das
wenn es jetzt wirklich
zunehmendreibereien käme zwischen diesen
beiden also ich glaube die Einigkeit ist
ganz ganz entscheidend und silence hat
er in diesem Krieg auch eine
entscheidende Rolle gespielt also dass
die Ukraine als Volk und Nationen sage
ich jetzt mal so zusammengehalten hat
dass sie die ganze Gesellschaft auch
diese kriegseinstellung getragen hat das
ist eben auch das Verdienst und ganz
wesentlich von silence gehen
möglicherweise ein ganz anderen
Kriegsverlauf gesehen wenn selinski in
den ersten Tagen getötet worden wäre
oder wenn er sich hätte evakuieren
lassen und sie haben es angesprochen die
die Zusammenarbeit mit dem Bürgermeister
von Kiew ist natürlich ganz wichtig der
ja auch sagen symbolisch stand für die
Verteidigung dieser Stadt als die
russischen Truppen vor den Toren der
Stadt standen aber was man sieht ist
natürlich die Ukraine kommt jetzt unter
Druck unter einen größeren Druck wie
noch im Sommer da war es nur in
Anführungsstrichen etwas militärisches
und engeren Sinne militärisch jetzt
haben wir eben ein ganz gezielter
Angriffe auf die zivile Infrastruktur
die übrigens nach der Kämpfer
Kombination verboten ist ganz klares
Kriegsverbrechen von Putin und es ist so
ein bisschen so bleiben also wer will
wie darstellen weil natürlich die
Bevölkerung sich Sorgen macht und weil
auch die politische Führung unter Stress
kommt weil die Forderung da ist also
macht was ähm verbessert unsere
Situation
also das ist ein Stück weit aus meiner
Sicht nachvollziehbar verständlich also
in diesen extremen Situation
nur zu lächeln und gar keine Differenzen
zu haben wäre glaube ich auch irgendwie
nicht erwartbar unmenschlich aber beide
müssen das wissen die auch alles daran
setzen eine Geschlossenheit des
ukrainischen regierungsapparats nach
außen zu demonstrieren noch halbwegs
durch den Winter zu kommen lass uns auch
auf die Soldaten schauen sowohl
natürlich auf der russischen wie auch
auf der ukrainischen Seite die in den
Schützengräben sind die wahrscheinlich
schlecht ausgerüstet denn wir sind die
ausgerüstet die können die zurechtkommen
nächsten Monaten nee das ist ähm eine
große Frage denn wir haben es ja hier
mit ich weiß nicht 100.000 plus Soldaten
auf der ukrainischen Seite zu tun und
etwa 200.000 auf der russischen Seite
und wir sehen zwar immer wieder
Handyvideos und so aber da will ich
wieder der Wissenschaft und sagen wie
repräsentativ ist das ne also wir sehen
natürlich Ukraine auch ukrainische
Gefangene mit Turnschuhen und ohne
Winterstiefel das sehen wir auch bei den
Russen wie repräsentativ ist das und
jede Seite versucht natürlich ein Bild
zu erzeugen also die anderen sind ja
praktisch Kanonenfutter
und da würde ich immer so ein bisschen
anmerken also
Armeen sind sehr komplex das ist sehr
heterogen und es gibt solche und solches
ich glaube dass die Ukraine insgesamt
versorgungstechnisch besser dasteht
als Russland russland hat das eben auch
viele viele
Verwaltungsprobleme auch bei dieser
mobilenmachung gegeben was eigentlich
verwundern kann weil das eben sehr
schnell über das Knie gebrochen wurde
weil sie um sehr viele Soldaten hier
reden und es ist natürlich eine
Herausforderung völlig klar diesen Krieg
im Winter zu führen also wir brauchen im
Winterkleidung nicht der Mensch kann
auch wenn es nur ähm schwächere
Minustemperaturen sind eben nachts nicht
in seiner Sommerkleidung da draußen
länger überleben und das durchstehen es
geht um Versorgung es geht um
Frostschutzmittel die der Verbrauch an
Treibstoff bei den Fahrzeugen ist größer
der Verschleiß und das ist vor allen
Dingen eine Herausforderung für die
Logistik und also wenn es Krieg führen
im Winter immer schwieriger immer
anspruchsvoller aber gerade wir
Deutschen denken dann immer bei Winter
kriegt ein Stalingrad oder Filter von
Moskau oder Napoleons Marsch nach Moskau
wir müssen jetzt auch sagen wir leben in
Zeiten des Klimawandels und wir haben
Gott sei Dank noch nicht -40 oder -30
Grad wie wir das im Zweiten Weltkrieg
hatten das waren noch ganz andere
Herausforderungen also ich würde sagen
ja es ist eine Herausforderung ja es ist
keine Freude jetzt in Schützengräben in
verschlanken Schützengräben oder auch
sozusagen in tiefgefrorenen schützen
Gremium je nach Region zu überleben und
zu kämpfen aber
die historischen Bedingungen wir können
es nicht mit den historischen
Bedingungen des zweiten oder auch das
ersten weltkriegsvergleichen das waren
ganz andere Rahmenbedingungen und da
sind dann auch 10.000 erfroren und das
ist nicht die Situation die wir jetzt
haben ich glaube das ist für beide
Armeen letztlich
Manager würden auf Englisch sagen aber
es ist eine Herausforderung für die
Soldaten
wie wir ihn in vielen anderen Kriegen
eben auch nicht also im Korea Krieg und
so weiter waren die Bedingungen
eigentlich noch viel schlimmer von daher
glaube ich
ja das ist schwieriger aber es gibt eben
für beide Seiten und von daher glaube
ich wird sich an dem Gleichgewicht und
so nicht substanziell etwas ändern was
ist denn sonst noch da an militärische
Ausrüstung das heißt die Drohnen die der
Iran offenbar an die Russen verkauft hat
seinen inzwischen so gut wie
aufgebraucht und haben wir vor zwei
Tagen eine Meldung bekommen dass
vermeintlich die Ukraine wiederum mit
Drohnen in Russland selber einen
Luftwaffenstützpunkt angegriffen haben
sollen vielleicht haben sie da mehr
Informationen verspannt zu hören Putin
hat in letzter Zeit immer wieder gesagt
Atomschlag nur wenn ich wirklich
angegriffen wäre werde wenn jetzt
wirklich die Ukraine dazu übergehen
würde auch gezielt in Russland
anzugreifen könnte das der viel
befürchtete gamechanger in Richtung
Atomschlag werden
also wir alle können nicht in Putins
Kopf schauen und niemand von uns sie
nicht ich nicht die sehr ähnlich der BND
nicht kann voraussagen was in einem
Monat passiert das muss man glaube ich
mal ganz deutlich so aussprechen wir
können nur Plausibilitäten aufzeigen
interpretieren und müssen immer dazu
sagen wir wissen nicht was passiert ist
das jetzt sagen einem verschärfte Gefahr
eines Atomkrieges glaube ich nicht denn
es sind letztlich Nadelstiche die die
Ukraine dort ausführen und Putin wird
nicht wegen eines drohenangriffes jetzt
den taktischen Nuklearschlag dafür ist
das auch zu unwichtig also was wir sehen
sie haben es auch mit den iranischen
Drohnen angesprochen ist eine Seite
bringt einen Kriegsmittel eine Waffe auf
den Kriegsschauplatz die andere Seite
reagiert die Ukraine haben die zum
großen Teil abgeschossen und so geht das
hin und her jeder versucht einen
technischen Vorteil zu haben eine Waffe
zu entwickeln auch ähm die Russen
reagieren auch die Russen sind in der
Lage durchaus jetzt auf die
Raketenangriffe Ukraine zu reagieren es
gibt Berichte dass die Russen in der
Lage sind auch heimatraketen
abzuschießen in bestimmten Fällen zum
Beispiel und es ist da eine weniger
große Wirkung gibt und das ist
eigentlich alles ganz normale Bild in
Anführungsstrichen des Krieges Aktion
und Reaktion und die Ukraine haben immer
wieder versucht an bestimmten Punkten
noch mit Spezialkräften auf das
russische Territorium zu wird mit ganz
einzelnen wenigen
Aktionen mehr haben hat die Ukraine auch
gar nicht also es ist nicht zu
befürchten dass jetzt die Ukraine einen
Luftkrieg gegen Russland beginnt und
Moskau bombardiert und dann Putin
nuklear antwortet also das sind
eigentlich sagen Dinge die natürlich
auch verwendet werden für den Propaganda
Krieg nicht einerseits die einstellen
das heraus und die anderen als
Terroristen darzustellen und so weiter
und so weiter aber ich glaube ähm aus
meiner Sicht gibt es diese
eskalationsschwelle nicht und meine so
so radikal Putin diesen Krieg auch führt
aber wir sehen eben auch Elemente
der Zurückhaltung also im Luftkrieg zum
Beispiel auch der Rückzug aus Cherson
nicht diese 20.000 Soldaten hätte Putin
auch da sterben lassen können also aus
rein militärischer Sicht betrachtet ist
die russische Seite rationaler als wir
das manchmal glauben
das hört sich ziemlich heftig an wenn du
sowas sagen muss ich mal kurz schlucken
trotzdem ich komme noch mal zurück zu
diesem drohen weil es ja doch am Ende
etwas war was sehr bemerkt worden ist
wie gesagt ich weiß nicht ob sie
konkrete Informationen haben es hieß
offenbar aber es ist doch wahrnehmbar
das erste Mal dass sie Ukraine wirklich
in tiefstes Inneres russisches Gebet
offenbar mit zwei Drohnen Angriff
gestartet haben glauben Sie dass sich
das intensiviert wird bis jetzt hatten
wir haben wir immer nur in
Anführungszeichen beobachtet das auf dem
Kanal der Ukraine passiert glauben Sie
dass sich das verändern wird in den
nächsten Monaten
also wir sagen die Nachrichtendienste
natürlich auch nicht das was ich gerne
wissen will weil diese Sachen dann
geheim sind und ich glaube nicht dass
zum Beispiel die Bundeswehr über diesen
Angriff wirklich Informationen von der
ukrainischen Seite bekommen hatte und
das ist ein großes Problem wir wissen
eigentlich über die Ukrainer weniger als
über die Russen weil es natürlich keinen
keine Aufklärung gibt und der BND hört
jetzt nicht den ukrainischen Funkverkehr
ab aber den russischen natürlich schon
also von daher also ich glaube ja die
Ukraine machen sowas es gibt einzelne
Formen aber das ist mehr für mich eine
ja eine Form des Symbolischen
Kommunikation im Krieg also dass man
sagt wir können das wir Schaden euch wir
nutzen das auch aus genauso wie es
Angriffe auf der Krim gegeben hat auf
die kernbrücke und so weiter die
vielleicht im engeren militärischen
Sinne gar nicht so entscheidend waren
aber die deutlich machen dass die
Ukraine Schwachstellen der russischen
Verteidigung ausnutzen können so ich
sehe nicht die Möglichkeiten der Ukraine
jetzt in einem größeren Umfang wirklich
großflächig Drohnenangriffe gegen
russische Städte oder russische
Militäreinrichtungen zu fliegen also das
ist für mich eine Einzelaktion solche
Aktion wird es vielleicht wiedergeben
aber das ist vor allen Dingen Teil eines
sage ich mal Propaganda Krieges und auch
eine mal ein Bild zu erzeugen die
Ukraine erzeugen das Bild wir sind sehr
leistungsfähig wir können das also
biowear wir können das wir können euch
auch im Hinterland treffen wir könnten
vielleicht auch weiter eskalieren also
das ist eher ein Teil dieses Spiels als
dass wir jetzt irgendwie ein totalen
anderen Krieg sehen werden das würde
mich sehr überraschen wenn wir das wenn
wir das sehen würden wenn wir jetzt
nochmal zur Kälte zurückkommen und zu
der gezielten Schwächung der oder
Zerstörung der kritischen Infrastruktur
in der Ukraine
wird glaube ich nicht nur dahinter
vermutet sondern es wird in der Tat auch
schon darüber diskutiert das Putin
nichts anderes damit intendiert als
weitere Flüchtlingsströme auszulösen
damit europäische Länder unter Druck zu
setzen zu destabilisieren weil es Streit
geben wird werden so viele auf er kann
noch etwas leisten
glauben Sie auch dass das eine gezielte
Strategie ist und ist das eine einige
Strategie die sie aus ihrer
militärhistorie kennen
also ich würde auch sagen dass Putin
alles daran setzt den Westen zu
schwächen und ich glaube auch das noch
mal um was geht es eigentlich in diesem
Krieg ich glaube es geht in engeren
Sinne gar nicht um die Ukraine sondern
es geht ich würde es groß interpretieren
es geht um die Schwächung der
euro-atlantischen Weltordnung und der
Euro atlantischen Ordnung damit um die
Schwächung Europa ist möglichst die USA
aus aus Mitteleuropa rauszudrängen da
aus Europa rauszubringen und dafür ist
die Ukraine ein Tool ein Mittel und da
ist wirklich Erzeugung von
Flüchtlingsströmen auch was Putin mit
seiner Luft in Syrien gemacht hat ein
Mitteln eines Hybriden Kriegs das ist
dieser Krieg wird konventionell geführt
er wird aber auch Hybrid geführt und da
ist die die Solidarität der Europäer die
wir bisher gesehen haben erstaunliche
Maße gesehen haben ein ganz wichtiges
Gut was wir dagegen setzen wollen und
ich glaube das putinen beide Seiten
vielleicht ein Stück weit Glauben
längerfristig am stärkeren Hebel zu
sitzen und ich glaube das Putins
Rezeption wie sie genau wissen wir
natürlich natürlich nicht ist ich kann
diesen Krieg länger durchhalten ich kann
eskalieren lassen und ihr Demokratien
seid schwach und ihr werdet zum Beispiel
mit diesen Problemen nicht umgehen
können und entweder gibt es ein
Flüchtlingsstrom der euch weiter
schwächen wird oder
die Situation für die ukrainischen
Zivilisten wird so unerträglich das ist
Druck auf silence gibt vielleicht doch
Frieden zu schließen ich glaube trotzdem
dass ich Putin damit verkalkuliert und
dass diese Bilder die wir haben von
ziviler Infrastruktur die angegriffen
wird von von zivilen Toten und
Verletzten von frierenden Mütter mit
ihren Kindern dass das eher den Westen
zusammenschließt und das ist deutlich
macht wie dort Krieg geführt wird und
das eben die Kämpfer Konvention nicht
geachtet wird und welche Radikalisierung
dieser Krieg hat und das wird glaube ich
eher ein Druck auf die westlichen
Regierung verstärken noch mehr zu tun um
der Ukraine zu helfen
westlichen Regierungen bleiben und mal
zur Zeitenwende kommen über die wir viel
gehört haben und ich glaube über die sie
sich auch lautstark gefreut haben als
wir verkündet worden wenn ich nicht
richtig erinnere haben wir nur viel
davon gehört und wenn ich davon gesehen
wie beurteilen Sie das ja also
seitenwende großes Wort kannst du das
Scholz ist damit im Wort national und
international und ja ich habe in dieser
Tage irgendwo mal geschrieben dass wir
gerade dabei sind die zeitenwände mit
Karacho gegen die Wand zu fahren und
warum wie komme ich zu diesem Urteil ich
glaube das ist um nicht weniger geht als
die Neugründung der Streitkräfte wir
haben die Bundeswehr unsere Streitkräfte
über auslandsansätze auf afghanistani
ich sag mal ein bisschen verkürzt über
Brunnenbohren und einen bewaffnetes
Technisches Hilfswerk gedacht das war
für eine gewisse Zeit auch gut so war
die soziale Praxis aber jetzt geht's um
Landes- und bündnisverteilung eigentlich
schon seit 2014 da hat jeder jeder
politische Wille gefehlt
einem Weißbuch einem
fähigkeits-profil der Bundeswehr
wirklich Taten folgen zu lassen jetzt
zeitenwender rede neue Regierung neue
internationaler Rahmen und es geht ja
darum Deutschland ist ein großes Land
und Deutschland eine ganz wichtige
Aufgabe bei einer potenziellen
Verteidigung des Bündnisses und es geht
auch um Abschreckung also kampweg zu
sein damit es nie zu einem Ernstfall
kommt und das sind die Deutschen im
besonderen Maße gefragt und wir müssen
einfach sagen unsere PS auf den Boden
bringen und das aus meiner Sicht also
Zeit ist ein ganz wichtiger Faktor und
wir kriegen unsere PS nicht auf dem
Boden weil im Bereich der Bundeswehr im
Bereich der Rüstung der Stadt sich
selbst im Wege steht wie in vielen
anderen Bereichen auch und wir haben
eine völlig verbürokratisierte
Institution Bundeswehr die dysfunktional
ist das weiß jeder es gibt auch
Vorschläge das zur reformieren aber wir
brauchen mehr
entscheidungswille
Entscheidungsfreude auch in einem großen
Sinne nicht nur einen kleinen Dingen um
diese rechten Wände wirklich Realität
werden zu lassen aber wo sind denn
unsere pS Wenn Sie sagen wir müssen die
auf dem Boden bringen auf der einen
Seite absolviert unsere
Verteidigungsministerin Termine und
sorgt dafür dass jetzt doch schneller
warme Kleidung angeschafft wird für
Bundeswehrsoldaten es gibt einen
munitionsgipfel im Kanzleramt und die
Konsequenz davon ist dass er sagt wir
haben keine Munition also da frage ich
mich doch wo sind wo sind diese PS also
das ist ein munitionsgipfel im
Kanzleramt gibt ist ja ein
Misstrauensvotum gegen die Ministerin
denn ich habe nicht gehört dass es in
anderen Ministerien es gibt viel im
Kanzleramt geben muss und wir haben
immer noch die ressour Hoheit und
eigentlich ist die Aufgabe von der
Ministerin diese Dinge die zeitenwände
im militärischen Sinne umzusetzen und
wenn das alles läuft müsste es keinen
Munition Kanzleramt geben also auch dass
das letztlich durchgestochen wurde an
die Presse das ist diesen
munitionsgipfel gibt es ja auch geheim
machen können ist aus meiner Sicht ein
Misstrauensvotum gegen die Ministerin so
und gerade bei der Munition sind das ja
Nachrichten aus runter wenn man jetzt
also mehr Material bestellt
Panzerhaubitzen und so weiter und man
dann einem anfällt oh wir haben aber
keine ausreichende Munition das ist
weder im Sondervermögen abgebildet noch
im Haushalt
und wenn dann Finanzminister Lindner
sagt ja weil die Frau Ministerin
Lamprecht hat das nie in den
nachtragsaufsatzverhandlungen prioritär
deutlich gemacht ist das innerhalb der
Koalition auch wieder ein Basic also das
ist alles nicht gut ich kann nur als
Bürger sagen das interessiert mich alles
überhaupt nicht ich will zum Schluss
eine funktionsfähige Bundeswehr haben
und das wird Jahre dauern völlig klar
man kann auch diese Munition nicht über
Nacht bestellen aber das Mindeste was
wir verlangen können ist ein rationales
schnelles effizientes Regierungshandeln
anderen Bereichen auch aber auch in
diesem Bereich und da muss man einfach
ein dickes Fragezeichen setzen ich
glaube nicht dass diese Dringlichkeit
ähm
bei allen Spitzenbeamten bei einigen
schon aber nicht bei allen Spitzen
wirklich angekommen ist und wir müssen
mal out of the box denken
wir müssen auch meine Sachen immer
außerhalb der Besoldungsgruppe denken
und es geht ums Land es geht um die
gesamtinstitution um diese Aufgaben und
nicht nur um das Kleinklein in dem
eigenen Aufgabenbereich und wenn ich das
Interview der Ministerin in der FAZ lese
dann ist das für mich ein
Abgesang an jegliches Strategie ein
Abgesang einen jegliche große Fragen die
einfach anstehen und ich würde mir von
einer Ministerin ich habe überhaupt gar
nichts gegen Frau Lamprecht aber
erwarten dass sie die großen Fragen
angeht nicht wie soll europäische
rüstungskooperation funktionieren wie
bringen wir gibt es welche
rüstungsstrategie gibt es nicht ein
Generalplan im Munition in die nächsten
in die nächsten Jahre damit die
Industrie sich darauf einstellen kann
alle zusammenholen einen
Krisenmanagement Board der wichtigsten
Abteilungsleiter im BMVg bei der Rüstung
all das sehen wir nicht und ähm jetzt
können wir auch nicht völlig hinter die
Kulissen schauen aber ich glaube da ist
noch viel Luft nach oben und Olaf Scholz
wird den politischen Preis bezahlen
müssen denn die Bündnispartner werden
irgendwann fragen die NATO
Olaf wo sind deine Legionen die hast du
uns versprochen und dann ist es eben
nicht immer
ausreichend dass man das einfach auf dem
Papier macht sondern die NATO wird
irgendwann diese Division die
versprochen ist sehen wollen mit
Ausrüstung mit Funkgeräten mit IT und so
weiter also da ist jetzt einfach
ist notwendig wirklich als Krisenmanager
zu handeln und da haben wir bisher bei
der Führung des Hauses noch viel Luft
nach oben also unabhängig von dem
Portfolio das eine
Verteidigungsministerin im Moment
abdecken müsste was natürlich auch
vorher keine Ahnung konnte ist es ja nun
auch so dass seit Wochen immer wieder
die Diskussionen gehen müsste sie
abgelöst werden oder nicht wenn sie
Berater werden von Olaf Scholz wenn sie
sie ersetzen ja die Frage ist immer also
wie geht es ja gar nicht um Personen wer
kann das besser gibt es jemanden der es
besser kann
das ist schwer zu sagen wir haben
insgesamt in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ein Problem dass wir
eigentlich nicht Politiker haben die
nach diesem Amt Streben der einzige der
wirklich verteilungsminister werden
wollte in der Geschichte war Manfred
Wörner und alle anderen kamen mehr oder
weniger Kenntnis frei in dieses Amt
ich glaube dass wir ich sage ich würde
es mal neutral beantworten nicht ihre
kleine Fangfrage
und sagen wir brauchen eine Hausleitung
die die großen Reform durchführt wir
brauchen eine Hausleitung die wirklich
die zeitenwände umsetzt die auch
deutlicher Ansagen Kabinett macht ist ja
bestimmte Gesetze verändern müssen mehr
verändern müssen wir brauchen auch
jemand mit einem breiten Rücken der sagt
ich will Reform und ich kann Reform und
das durchdrückt das sehe ich zurzeit bei
der Hausleitung nicht
nun gucken sie ja auch auf viele andere
westliche Partner und haben viel Kontakt
irgendwie zu Kollegen in den anderen
Ländern wie wird denn von außen geschaut
auf Deutschland im Moment und dieses
Versprechen der Zeitenwende gute Frage
also die die Rede von Olaf Scholz hat im
Ausland eine Normen Eindruck gemacht in
Washington in London in Paris zum Teil
so ein bisschen um das können wir nicht
auch bei der NATO nicht die Briten haben
halt keine 100 Milliarden Franzosen
haben keine 100 Milliarden und das wurde
zum Teil auch bei der NATO so gespielt
zusammen sieht man was die Deutschen
machen was macht ihr denn
aber die Enttäuschung das jetzt so wenig
folgt dass die Deutschen wieder sich
völlig in ihrer Bürokratie in ihrem
friedensbetrieb verfangen ist eben enorm
die wird natürlich diplomatisch verpackt
das wird ihnen keiner offen ins Gesicht
sagen aber wenn man mal mit den Leuten
ein Bier trinken geht und hinter die
Kulissen schaut ist die Enttäuschung
gerade in Ost Mitteleuropa enorm und
auch das Misstrauen gegen die Deutschen
mit traut diesen Worten nicht und wir
haben in Deutschland zu viel zu viel
reden zu viel Blabla zu viel Schönwetter
reden aber zu wenig Handlung nicht wir
reden über Elefanten und wir dann kommen
zum Schluss gebären eine Maus nicht und
das haben die Partner schon zu oft
erlebt und deswegen gibt es eine große
Skepsis und ich glaube nicht dass wir so
durchkommen wie sonst immer die 2014 zu
sagen ja ja da machen wir drei
Divisionen und so weiter alles toll aber
wir unterlegen das nicht mit Finanzen
und uns intern klar dass wir das gar
nicht erfüllen können damit werden wir
diesmal nicht durchkommen
nun ist die EU ja gerade wieder damit
beschäftigt ein weiteres sanktions Paket
zu schnüren gegen Russland ich glaube
das ist inzwischen das neunte sanktions
Paket das kommen soll den normalen
Bürger oder die normale Bürgerin wie
mich verwundert das etwas ehrlich gesagt
weil hätten wir nicht direkt also es ist
ja schon erstaunlich dass es immer
wieder noch steigerbar ist hätten wir
nicht direkt ganz anders auffahren
müssen da ja All-In gehen am Anfang und
da bin ich eigentlich mitteilen habe ich
der Meinung
dass es sinnvoll war das nicht zu tun
denn es gab ja die Forderung nicht also
sämtliche Verbindung zu kacken auch
sämtliche Öl und Gasimporte aber dann
wer hat ihn in Deutschland hier die
Licht das Licht ausgegangen und vor
allen Dingen das Licht der Industrie
ausgegangen und wir müssen schon sehen
das Argument fand ich treffend dass der
Industriestandort Deutschland überleben
muss und die Herausforderungen sind ja
schon jetzt groß genug auch für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sind ja schon
jetzt groß genug also wenn man das noch
radikaler gefahren hätte wäre glaube ich
der wirtschaftliche Schaden immens
gewesen und wir müssen auch ökonomisch
diesen Krieg lange durchhalten das ist
keine Sache die morgen vorbei ist also
von daher ist glaube ich Augenmaß ähm
wichtig jetzt bin ich kein
Wirtschaftsexperte ich muss auch als
Bürger mich da auf die Kenntnis des
Kanzleramts das ähm
Wirtschaftsministerium verlassen ich
glaube man konnte nicht nichts machen
aber muss auch in diesem Konvoi der
europäischen Staaten fahren und das
einigermaßen mit augenmaßen machen wohl
wissend
weg aber ich glaube dass wir
wirtschaftlich schon auch am längeren
Hebel setzen wir sind wirtschaftlich
stärker als Russland die letzte Frage an
den Militärexperten allerdings zu einem
doch etwas anderen Thema es gab in den
letzten Tagen eine große Razzia mit sehr
vielen Festnahmen der
sogenannten reichsbürger-szene unter den
Festgenommenen sollen auch mehrere hohe
Militärs sein also auch
Bundeswehrsoldaten und so weiter hat sie
das überrascht also soweit ich es bisher
weiß wann das ehemalige
Bundeswehrsoldaten und keine aktiven und
das der aktive Dienst liegt bei einigen
also viele Jahre zurück nein
überraschend ist das nicht also wir
haben ja etliches Skandale gehabt auch
Rechtsradikalismus Rechtsextremismus war
seit Gründung der Bundeswehr immer auch
ein Problem diese Fehler gab es immer
und der immer die hat ja auch immer auch
im zweistelligen Bereich Leute
identifiziert auch aus den Streitkräften
ausgeschlossen was manchmal gar nicht so
einfach war also das ist rechtsextreme
in der Bundeswehr gab das wussten wir
die zu Bundeswehr geforscht haben immer
und dass wir dann
das ist jetzt eine solche Verschwörung
möchte ich das fast nennen gab dass
dabei auch Leute mit mit Bundeswehr
Hintergrund
auftauchen das hat mich nicht verwundert
und aber mich hat es eher gesagt also
ich sehe eine solche Sache jetzt eher
positiv in Sinne von offenbar arbeiten
die Sicherheitsbehörden ja zuverlässig
haben das enttarnt weit bevor es
irgendeinem Anschlag gekommen sind das
ist für mich dann immer entscheidend
nicht dass wir Sicherheitsbehörden haben
denn immer den Verfassungsschutz die
Polizei die natürlich auch auf solche
Kreise schaut und uns vor solchen Toren
bewahrt unsere Zeit ist leider schon
vorbei Hannah herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch vielen Dank
[Musik]